our next guest is one of the most famous
radio personalities in the country
his unfiltered talent like it is candor
has even made him a radio hall of famer
and now he's brought his raw honesty to
the television screen with his new show
the gods honest truth with charlemagne
the god and he is here today revealing a
side of him that you haven't heard but
first let's check this out are we a
society that's really meant for monogamy
i'm willing to bet that it depends on
how attractive you are if you have an
unfortunate face then you're more likely
to be good and faithful
what
okay
but there's attractive men who still
believe in monogamy like me
please welcome charlemagne
um one of the things i really found
interesting in my research of you was
that you have four kids four daughters
one network i breed queens
[Applause]
i have a thirteen-year-old a
six-year-old a three-year-old in the
newborn so we grew up
differently different circumstances
different places and spaces but i think
we're very connected on something and i
was curious
as to why
i don't want my kids on social media i
just feel that this is what's right for
me
how come you feel that way i don't want
uh my kids seeking validation from
anybody other than the people that truly
truly love them because imagine growing
up in the era that we grew up in where
you know your every single move
is broadcasted via social media like we
got to be allowed to make mistakes and
then it's that weird awkward phase right
like i remember in sixth grade when i
had like glasses in the fanny pack and
my glasses used to always fall off my
face and they were crooked so when i
took my school picture the glasses were
crooked like i don't want kids getting a
hold of that and then i'm a meme for the
rest of my life is that that's not the
worst thing they're gonna find out about
you and you know that's probably gonna
just become a fashion trend the next day
maybe but then like it's really for me
it's just really the self-esteem thing i
just don't think that people are meant
to be
that connected like i shouldn't be it
shouldn't be thousands of people
weighing in on their opinion
of you
you think that doesn't get to you but it
does chip away at you
i don't think that any human being is
impervious to negative comments it's
it's human nature to be hurt by those
arrows and you end up projecting that
pain whether you realize it or not like
you might you know
take it in and then suppress it and tell
yourself that it doesn't bother you but
then you just go around projecting that
pain in the hurt on every on everybody
else i agree so it's impossible to take
in all that negative energy and then not
project it you know to the world i miss
the days when it was just talking about
politics and it wasn't so personal
it's almost impossible though now right
because now when you look at somebody's
politics you think that is a
indictment of what that person is about
but i think that is because of the the
trump era right like when you saw racism
and bigotry at the forefront like you
did you just assumed okay if you're a
trump supporter then you're just
naturally a racist and a big that's not
always the case maybe 75 of the time i
just don't want to hate people for what
they believe in and i don't want to be
hated for being who i am and i just
absolutely i'm i'm a lean towards
whoever i see truly caring about the
people and for me that's neither party
at this point so you want it to be equal
opportunity and you want to fight for
people i thought that's what america was
about yeah that's what they tell us at
least yeah well that's what's on the
marquee you know freedom justice liberty
equality for all but you know that's
they've been doing some bad uh marketing
for years
and that's why i don't mind having the
conversations and i say bring it on
because you might learn something or
reveal that is my biggest problem with
like the
dating app world who can tell from a
photograph who that person is and how
you're going to connect with them i know
it's a weird correlation but i just
think i don't know nothing about that i
just
i don't well i couldn't even imagine
trying to date in 2021 and having to be
on dating apps like that's terrifying
well because you're talking about
getting to know somebody and the more we
put everything in a technological veneer
the less we're actually having that
engaged peeling back the layers that's
why what mark zuckerberg is doing with
meta is so dangerous people are already
living in like this delusional alternate
reality now i can just create my own
world where is the incentive to be
something in life if i could just sit in
my house and just create this you know
fantasy land where i got everything the
way that i wanted like ugh how come also
we just skipped right over
like
social media and the way it's affecting
teenagers
what was that parlay into
ignoring all of that and the
accountability
to how human beings are going to
function in this world we're just going
to go layers deeper right and that's
that's going to be the crazy part 10
years from now what's going to be the
impact of social media
on on on people like i just don't think
we're a design like the way we're always
looking down the way we see things
through the lens of social media all the
time like some people can't even
formulate their thoughts yeah until they
get on social media to see what
everybody else is thinking that is scary
i agree i know the meta thing i was like
wait this is the answer it's like it's
gonna be like avatar yeah and remember
at the end of avatar that dude did not
come back he liked living in that
fantasy world yes
yeah right because he had nala too
that's what i'm saying um
i
love the way you talk about the present
i'm interested in your conversations
about where the future lies
what is it in you
whether it's the study of charlemagne
and finding that name when you were
younger
and the author that we're about to meet
through your imprint
what is it about history that you find
so compelling and important to bring
into the modern day with you oh well if
you don't you know know from which you
came then you know you won't really know
where you're at and you damn sure won't
know where you're going and you know my
mom was an english teacher so like i
grew up with the bookit program where
you had to read four books to get a free
pizza and and she and she and she always
was telling me she would always tell me
read things that don't pertain to you so
i grew up reading like judy bloom and
beverly clearly oh my god nothing's fair
in fifth grade
ramona quimby are you there it's me
margaret
oh you are a must-have girl oh for real
so it's like you know i just i just you
know picked up everything growing up
like everything so i would read and she
was my mom was jehovah witness i grew up
jehovah witness too so i would just read
like my book of bible stories like
anything i could get my hands on i would
read so i'll just i'm just intrigued
about the world period
i love that
[Music]
you